so my four years in green bay were a
train wreck
and i was there wasn't you know a single
day in green bay
where i was like stone cold sober it was
either some kind of a pill in me
there was anything that would alter me
from the chin up right um
in my brain where i was drinking or i
was doing something now that doesn't
mean i was sloppy down falling down
drunk drinking but i would need a drink
to stop the shakes
and then go to practice wow right well
it's kind of hard to pass block
in the nfl period let alone when you're
half in the bag
yeah so you know looking back at a lot
of those things
and being going through all that pain
like i got
into so much emotional pain i was sick
and tired of my own [ __ ] oh man
that's too that's that's right right
it's exactly where i'm at right now
and that's part of myself that's when we
change sick of yourself right like
literally people like what are you on
and you're like i'm on myself right
and it's [ __ ] killing me like it
people don't understand sometimes and
that's a lot of what i think addiction
is for me i don't even know sometimes if
i've ever had a lot of chemical
dependency
as much as i
the way i'm feeling affects me so
heavily
right like it's a drug like to the point
where it's like and then i become
addicted to it
and at the same time suffering from it
yeah and i think people sometimes can't
understand
some of that like what it's like to feel
that way right
and it's and they're like you're a wimp
or you're this man it's like you think i
don't
want you think i want to feel this way
every day when i wake up you think i
want to be angry or be
miserable or you know like i know this
is something that's happening
to me and it's hard to handle right yeah
and
and you know i mean and listen you're
it's like again are you following me
around because you're telling me my
story right it's exactly how i feel and
i don't feel it i still get definitely
times like that
but less and less yeah and and it'll
change
i've been you know over 25 years now
almost 26 years sober
and wow but you know what like the first
three years were
like just like you could have cut me off
you could have done
robbed me i would have been like alright
here you go cool have a good day i was
so
happy not to be miserable yeah right oh
the beginning of sobriety when you're
like
when you see when something happens
there's a perspective switch and the way
you see
the world in the way that it really is
god bro yeah when
it literally like you talked about the
four or five days or two weeks before
you took steroids
you never thought you would take
steroids four days before i got sober
i never thought i'd be in a treatment
center four days later wow and that was
a decision i made right and
because of the emotional pain and i was
just looking in the mirror and discussed
it
at what i saw and all the i was like
what a
bunch of [ __ ] and lies and deceit
and just and it just gets so hard you
stack up so much stuff it's just too
heavy
and it's so interesting you had so much
weight on your body
like so much and it was like but then
you get this relief
of all of this [ __ ] weight crazy that
which is just almost so ironic and
you're like it's crazy in your space
but in today like like you talk about
like today's circumstance
when i do feel the way like you know if
i feel like a shitty day or it's like
like i'm sabotaging myself or whatever i
know why it's because i'm not connected
i'm not either talking to people or i'm
not or i haven't like for me
i haven't hit my knees in the morning
and asked for help well when you're
i think that this is a powerful thing
when you're six five like now six five
265 whatever
when you hit your knees and you are
praying to the god of your belief
and asking for help through the day and
asking about what you can add to the
stream of life instead of sucking out of
the stream of life
for a change that's a pretty humbling
experience
when you're that big a stature so you
know i was doing that when i was
six six you know playing for the colts
at six six
three fifteen three twenty strong as an
ox
and it's it's a very humbling experience
knowing you're
knowing how powerful you are right and i
could make stuff happen like i can make
things happen
by the old phrase just grab the ball by
the horns just make it happen
if you got to step on people's toes do
it just make it happen
it's like i don't care how you got to
block this guy just don't get a penalty
and block him i don't care if you got to
take his knees out whatever right it's
like go to any lengths to protect your
quarterback
so it's it's kind of like that but it's
like you know it's
when you have that stature that size
that power and you're in the weight room
slinging weight around and all this
but in the morning you know when you get
on your knees and ask for help that's a
humbling
it's a humbling act yeah yeah yeah
and you know it's like it's basically
saying you know i can't do this by
myself
i tried and almost killed myself yeah
almost killed myself trying
yeah because i'll never forget when i'm
in the treatment center in detroit
and was no fancy treatment center and
this was the first time you ever went
into treatment
first time so you went in and got it
yeah i'm not gonna do it again right
yeah um and uh okay take us there no the
girl the girl the
lady counselor it was their first like
small like
10 people session with a counselor and
it was all our first time with this
meeting and she goes
um so before we start she's like this
isn't pointing anybody out she's like
this applies to everybody she's like
just before we start i just want you all
to know that all of your best plans
of building your empires and building
everything got you here in this
treatment center in detroit michigan
and i can see like i know you know
90 or whatever it is going by the
interstate i'm going she's right
and i was like talking about a
louisville slugger coming across your
forehead going
holy [ __ ] that reality
yeah yeah i mean funny now wasn't funny
then
yeah but i'm trying i'm trying to think
of some of those first moments that
you know whenever i went into the rooms
because mostly i learned about recovery
through my family my
i have siblings that are you know in and
out or been in the program and um
and probably my father i mean i think so
many people struggle with addiction to
different things
but i remember getting i remember i
drove through the parking lot one night
of a
of a room that's not far from where i
live and
i was talking to my brother something
the next day and he said well you know
who's not thinking about getting
treatment and i said
he uh i said who he goes people that
people that aren't driving through that
parking you know i'm saying like not
everybody's driving through the parking
lot of an aaa
center last night you know i'm saying
like there's something inside of you
that's curious that's thinking like
and i think sometimes it is there's a
magnet that's created by that program
um you know last night i went to a
meeting and i went over to a buddy's
house and
uh and i got there and i hadn't been in
probably like three months to his
meeting and
um it's just like six or seven guys
sitting outside by a fire right
and i get there and suddenly like i
walked around the group and just hugged
like every guy there i know them all
right
and it was funny because i just had the
worst day and i get there and uh
and i was like man i didn't know that i
was gonna hug all these guys when i got
here i forgot that
and they were all so excited to see me
like each individually we have our own
little relationship and like
i just i forgot that all these guys
cared about me and i forgot that i cared
about them like it's just like
camaraderie
yeah and unless i like the half-life or
the residual effect of like
care it doesn't the shelf life isn't
long inside of me for some long it's
you know it's really it's almost like
the shelves are like at an angle and
when somebody puts care on them
they just slide it just and i don't know
why i think it was just the way the
shelves were built or something you know
but
it was just crazy because next thing you
know it was like the best moment of my
day
and all these guys was like man i always
feel like nobody cares but
these guys care they all care and i care
about them and i just freak
it just it doesn't stick to my ribs like
i wish it would a lot of times so that's
why
i think some people are like man you
chase your tail a lot it's like because
i forget that that that the tail
is there i forget that it how it grew
the tail's wagging the dog yeah right
oh yeah it's like um i don't know it's
just it's it's all fascinating man the
program is pretty fascinating your
recovery uh
it works so so take us a little bit more
so
so you you have that experience with
your brother kind of and then you get
into it and then
you're playing at michigan state then
good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watches
one
ah